the refs are not throwing any flags out
on the field this is madness to the 20
what's going on everybody I'm Travis
Kelce and today I partnered up with
State Farm to host my FIRST robotics
tournament here at the 87 and running
robotics lab now the winner of the
tournament will face myself in a grand
finale and hopefully I can keep up with
the kids let's have a blast I know you
guys been working hard coding and
building all these robots so today we're
putting it to use
everybody's gonna help me out let's dive
into it where do we start operation
breakthrough serves the entire Kansas
City community like no other when it
came to helping fund the robotics lab
here at operation breakthrough and the
stump program that they have going on
here
the first thing that came to my mind was
how important it is for kids to
understand what exactly technology is at
a young age I'm assuming this is the
engine yeah I already I know what I'm
doing out here now more than ever once
you get behind it's harder than ever to
catch back up lower-income families
families who don't have the advantage of
having a computer at home or a computer
at school they fall behind and I wanted
to create something here at operation
breakthrough that gave them that
opportunity to take advantage of
technology at a young age ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls welcome to the
first 87 and running Robotics
Competition the first one to get from
this end zone to this ends on the
fastest will move on and the winner of
the entire tournament will play myself
in a grand finale championship game are
you ready
first one to the other endzone wins on
your marks get set go the refs are not
throwing any Flags out on the field this
is madness not really sure how to feel
right now I've never done this before
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
because you guys have been so good
you're an operation breakthrough and you
guys are standing out so much with this
robotics lab we have come together and
got you each your own personal robotics
kit to take home so you guys can have
some fun at the house State Farm we want
to say thank you for helping us today
operation breakthrough we want to say
thank you and today's a wrap I had a
blast you guys have a blast yeah until
the next time everybody please
[Music]